the jurgen experience and then that
brings us to
lazar's depiction of how these things
worked
that they somehow another bend gravity
these things that he worked on which is
the model that's on the desk there let's
uh supposedly a detailed model of what
that thing
looked like that he worked on the sport
model i think they called it that's what
he called it
yeah when you watch him talk and you
hear him
give his description of his time working
there and what he saw
and what he thinks those things are what
was your take on that
i thought it was curious and interesting
i mean i've been to area 51 i didn't see
any flying saucers or
any thing like that what did you see
i saw uh defense department uh
uh experiments being performed and and
training activities and that sort of
thing
nothing that the taxpayer would uh
object to but of course not but it's a
big range there's a lot of stuff going
on out there and there's a lot of
adjacent ranges
uh if you look at this form where he was
that's what he said yeah
i found his explanations curious yeah
how so
the the complexity of it uh and the fact
that he talked about laurentium for
example and
then decades later it turns out that um
apparently there is a more stable form
of that than that's element 115.
i sounds right i couldn't tell you but
it's called laurentium
that sounds like something from
battlestar galactica you know we need
this all this stuff yeah right
right so uh now i i'm a little skeptical
about his claims i have to say
um a friend of mine uh
claims to know that the gal who is his
supervisor
when he worked out there and knows what
he was was actually doing and where he
was located
and claims that that he was a guy who
checked radiation on badges
that's it yeah and so all the rest is
fiction
according to that story uh and this is a
person that you know
yeah maybe that person's full of [ __ ]
maybe you know i i don't have the ground
truth on this yeah but
it's interesting he did falsify his
educational records
and he's been involved in some other
things and uh
and it just doesn't you talking about
the mit records
yeah yeah he explained that to me he
said that he was working on something
for the government at and they sent him
to mit
to learn something and he
i can't say too much i'll tell you off
air because he told me not to talk about
it
but it makes more sense when you hear
his description of it that
essentially it wasn't documented
that he was studying there because what
he was doing
was really a terrible thing a terrible
experiment they were working on when i
explained to you
maybe it'll make more sense okay maybe
not though
maybe he's full of [ __ ] maybe he lied
about that what's interesting though is
he's
told the same exact story since
the late 80s and he doesn't seem full
[ __ ] now some people
are really good at lying and uh you know
i've been tricked before and i'm sure
you have too there's some people that
are just
sociopaths they're really good at yeah
they don't even like know they're lying
they're
yeah convinced in their own head while
they're spinning it he's obviously
though
he's obviously very intelligent and he
obviously knows a lot about science he
knows a lot about propulsion systems and
and he really did work at los alamos
which is interesting because he's
actually on
the employee roster and they tried to
say that he didn't
he knew people that were there he knew
the layout of the building when he went
there with george knapp
they went through the building he knew
exactly where everything was and he knew
the people that worked there
so he really did work there apparently
allegedly
his story what's interesting to me is
that
again it's the same story over and over
and over again
and then what's also interesting to me
is that he
knew and took friends to a place where
they were testing these things out
and he knew where it was and he knew
when they were doing it and he brought
his friends out there and that's when
they got arrested
yeah it's a very uh
i think there's some consistency there
that is hard to explain how would he
know where to go and right
what was going on um there are some
possible answers to that i've poked into
this a bit um
supposedly there was a bar off base
where
the scientists and a lot of the aviators
and people go and hang out he was a
frequent frequented that place and
picked up information
so you know i i hear stories on both
sides of this
um i don't know what the what the ground
truth is
and uh uh i i remain skeptical but
yeah you know hey there's a lot of crazy
stuff going on i enjoyed his company
i i went to dinner with him and jeremy
and uh
i talked to him for several hours uh
on the podcast and off the podcast i uh
i don't know
you know i don't bet it's some it's a
weird one because he never made any
money doing that
you never made any money telling that
story i'll tell you another story
offline we can exchange
stories offline i'm excited i can't wait
for this to be over now
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other
apps and can download episodes to save
on data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience